ich werde ein spannungsfeld diskutieren
zwischen bestimmten form
naturalistischer sichtweisen und der art
und weise wie man mit besonderheiten der
humanen lebensform umgeht
ich werde aber den blick auf grund der
naturalistischen perspektive nicht nur
auf diese form der humanen lebensform
werfen ist es schön zu sehen dass
naturalisten und anti naturalisten wenn
sie dann über die besondere form der
human ausgestaltung des lebens reden
interessanterweise immer über die erste
und die zweite person reden müssen
dazu kommt dass der begriff der
lebensform nicht anthropozän trish
ausgerichtet ist wenn man ihnen ohne das
adjektiv verwendet
wir reden über individuen und spezies
insgesamt und der begriff der lebensform
bezieht sich auf die natur von tieren
etwa im sinne von wesentlichen
bestimmungen wenn wir an alles denken
also wir haben es mit dem begriff der
lebensform schon vom semantischen ansatz
immer mit einbettung in die natur
geschichte zu tun und das werde ich
versuchen normativ mir zu nutze zu
machen
also wir werden die frage an einem punkt
beantworten müssen wie kann die humane
lebensform als solche eigentlich in die
scala natur eingebettet werden und dazu
werde ich eine vorschläge machen
ich werde das im wesentlichen
in drei schritten tun ich werde über den
naturalismus kurze rede und ein ganz
spezifisches verständnis von
naturalismus dort verteidigen dann werde
ich im griff der lebensform reden und
der konzeptionelle schlussteil wird das
sein was sich eine dichte beschreibung
nenne
und die wird versuchen diese eingangs
gestellten fragen dann zu beantworten
bei dem antwortet wieder fragen nach dem
was es gibt gelten die
naturwissenschaften als verlässliche
quelle
auch wenn die engen grenzen der
naturwissenschaftliche modell und
theoriebildung nicht zu leugnen sind
stellen sie vergleich zu anderen
erklärungs weisen den stall vom bloßen
meinungen oder weltanschauung sich als
methodisch belastbare heraus und gerade
in heutigen zeiten der sogenannten fake
news ist das etwas an das man definitiv
erinnern sollte die philosophie der
neuzeit ist von den
naturwissenschaftlichen weisen der welt
erklärung nicht unbeeindruckt geblieben
in ihren systematischen hauptströmungen
sucht sie schon seit dem siebzehnten
jahrhundert die nähe zu ontologischen
rahmenbedingungen die mit den
naturwissenschaften in einklang zu
bringen sind oder zumindest ihnen nicht
grundsätzlich widersprechen
dieser ansatz ist zu einem nicht
unbeträchtlichen teil auch für den
aufstieg so genannter naturalistischer
ansätze in der neueren und neuesten
philosophie verantwortlich der
gegenwärtige stand der
naturwissenschaften darf in seiner
geltung aber weder unterschätzt noch
überschätzt werden die
naturwissenschaften stellen für ihren
jeweiligen zuständigkeitsbereich die
beste art der wirklichkeit modelle zur
verfügung die wir haben aber es ist
darauf aufmerksam zu machen dass es
immer nur für ein spezifisches
zuständigkeitsbereich gilt fragen nach
dem was es gibt sind danach nicht zu
beantworten ohne sich an erweiterten
naturwissenschaftlichen fragestellungen
zu orientieren und vor allen dingen
auch sich über den state of the art der
jeweiligen naturwissenschaften im klaren
zu sein wie die orientierung im
einzelnen ausfallen muss ist anders als
der großteil gegenwärtiger natur
naturalistische ansätze unterstellt
keineswegs von vornherein ausgemacht das
ist etwas was sehr stören dass an vielen
natur naturalistischen ansätzen dass sie
eigentlich keine fragen der zulassung
jedenfalls was den ontologischen rahmen
angeht sondern immer schon eine
generelle antwort haben mit der
orientierung an die naturwissenschaften
stellt sich für den naturalismus aber
auf jeden fall die aufgabe zumindest
annäherungsweise den onkologischen
bereich systematisch kenntlich zu machen
der von den naturwissenschaftlichen
verfahren und modellen nicht erreicht
wird was übrigens ein
naturwissenschaftler in laborsituation
sowieso tut
viele eigenschaften und fähigkeiten der
humanen lebensform wer nicht innerhalb
des rahmens thematisiert den die
naturwissenschaften vorgeben was sie im
übrigen auch gar nicht wollen
das gilt insbesondere für moralische und
ästhetische einstellungen wie uns hier
natürlich besonders interessieren
dieser sachverhalt wird in der regel so
gedeutet dass unter den bedingungen
naturalistischer welt beschreibungen
selbstbewusstsein rationalität moralität
ästhetisches bewusstsein usw
ausgeklammert werden müssten die annahme
der ontologischen unüberbietbar kite der
naturwissenschaften scheint eine
gegenläufigkeit zwischen der ontologie
der wissenschaftlichen realismus in
verschiedensten ausprägungen einerseits
und den ontologischen voraussetzungen
praktischer philosophie andererseits zu
erzeugen
für vertreter des naturalismus die der
unüberbietbar kites these zustimmen muss
der anschein entstehen als würde in der
ethik oder ästhetik etwas thematisiert
werden für das innerhalb der
naturalistische welt beschreibung gar
kein platz vorgesehen ist
diese vermutung ist der anlass für eben
die schon mehrfach erwähnten natur
realisierungs programm vertreter eines
erweiterten methoden integrativen
naturalismus zu denen ich mich bekenne
gehen von einem natur philosophischen
ansatz aus der konzeptionellen raum für
lebenswelt argumente zulässt die person
als akteure von normativen
verhaltensweisen behandeln gewissheiten
die wir mit dem bewusstsein unserer
aktivitäten verbinden sind dieser
sichtweise folge naturwissenschaftliche
modellen nicht zwangsläufig
untergeordnet das ist wichtig zu
erwähnen dass lebenswelt argumente
keinesfalls in irgendwelchen
konkurrenzsituationen zu
naturwissenschaftlichen erklärung stehen
sondern sie sagen los ist muss im
einzelnen darüber verhandelt werden
welcher ansatz jetzt phänomen gerecht
eingesetzt werden kann
innerhalb des systems des
wissenschaftlichen realismus kommt die
naturwissenschaftlichen weltmodell
bestimmt eine methodische vorgehen
vorbeugung eine rolle zu er ist aber
nicht ausdruck eines disziplin er ein
ansatzes sondern hinter dem
wissenschaftlichen realismus verbirgt
sich sozusagen ein ganzer strauß von
ansätzen alle disziplinen die
methodische recht fertigungsfähigkeit
auch außerhalb des eigenen disziplin
ehren bereichs erreichen leisten einen
beitrag zur wirklichkeit auffassungen
des wissenschaftlichen realismus er
wissenschaftliche realismus ist insofern
ein arbeitsteiliges projekt musiknoten
um melodien sind genauso
rechtfertigungslehre worten auf die
frage was es gibt wie gene oder
naturgesetze schließlich muss beachtet
werden dass der wissenschaftliche
realismus kein stehendes und bleiben das
gefüge ist er repräsentiert immer die
neuesten disziplin ehren entwicklungen
oder sollte es zumindest
ungeachtet des sachverhalts dass der
disziplin disziplin ehre spektrum des
wissenschaftlichen realismus keineswegs
auf die naturwissenschaften beschränkt
ist ziehen zentis tische natur ali
sierung programme einseitige folgerungen
aus der ontologischen leistungsfähigkeit
ihres ansatzes also sie
reklamieren dann so ein erstgeborenen
recht in der familie des
wissenschaftlichen realismus aber auch
verfechter eines engen zentristische
naturalismus werden einräumen müssen
dass die systemische moralische oder
ästhetische einstellungen institution
konvention soziale regeln und normative
gesetze genauso wenig phänomen gerecht
erfassen kann wie kunstwerke musik oder
zahlen und er wird der sache nach nicht
so weit gehen können diese phänomene zu
läuten zumal er ständig selbst mit ihnen
umgeht oder auch sie reagiert die
unüberbietbar kites these feld gleichsam
invers auf den zentristischen
naturalismus zurück fragen nach der
wirklichkeit der moralität und danach
den normativen stellenwert von
handlungen kann der enge naturalismus
wieder abwehren noch aufgrund seines
methodischen ansatzes beantworten
deswegen arbeite ich mit einer form
eines erweiterten naturalismus oder auch
eines methoden integrativen naturalismus
der eine ontologische einheit der
wirklichkeit akzeptiert also man kommt
nicht aus dieser welt spekulativ heraus
und selbst wenn wir in eine postmortale
existenz eintreten bleibt alles das
woraus wir mal als sterbliche bestanden
haben innerhalb dieser welt das ist ein
nur mit der ontologischen einheit
gemeint und die es gibt ein vorrang des
des wissenschaftlichen standpunkt aber
das hängt vor allem mit den rechts
fertigungsverfahren zusammen weil wir
mit wissenschaftlichkeit ja immer auch
eine ganz bestimmte form des gebens und
nehmens von gründen verbinden was bei
weltanschaulichen ansetzen dann fehlt
eine weitere punkt der wichtig ist und
die nicht ersetzbarkeit von perspektiven
der ersten zweiten dritten person das
wird im dritten teil wenn ich über die
dichte beschreibung rede dann noch ein
bisschen
deutlicher werden um dieses spektrum von
erweiterten naturalismus naturalismus in
welcher prominente auch immer
wissenschaftlichen realismus und fragen
naturwissenschaftliche herausforderungen
zu klären scheint mir der begriff der
lebensform sehr günstig zu sein weil er
von anfang an auf ein aspekt aufmerksam
gemacht den wir bei der natur des
menschen zu berücksichtigen haben denn
wir reden wenn wir über die natur des
menschen reden in zweierlei hinsicht
darüber wir reden über die natur in
welcher der menschen lebt in dem wegen
der mensch lebt und das ist oft nicht
wirklich trennscharf auseinandergehalten
ob der menschen und wirklich auch noch
dazu gehört in vielen verwendung wird er
interessanterweise daraus gerechnet und
wir reden über die physische und
psychische verfassung des menschen nicht
im sinne von vielleicht traditionell
wesens bestimmungen und ich glaube der
witz des begriffs der lebensform ist
dass diese beiden bestimmungen in einem
sachlichen zusammenhang stehen und das
kann man glaube ich auch mit blick auf
die tradition sehr schön sagen wir
kennen alle diese vielen
entwicklungsstufen der natur also von
der körperlichen existent zur beliebten
existenz empfinden existenz oder
vernunftbegabten existenz haben diese
wunderbaren modelle der aber koreaner
oder das great chain of base wurde dann
immer eine gewisse unregelmäßigkeit an
den spiel kommt wenn man über das anime
rationale rede denn das fühlt sich in
der regel nicht dieser logik von
wartungs bestimmungen und der
spezifizieren den differenzen
ich arbeite für die belange einer
erweiterten form des naturalismus mit
einer abfolge von prädikaten wenn wir
schauen auf zeiträume von 13 milliarden
jahren mit der entstehung dieses
weltalls so wie wir es kennen denn
reicht im grunde genommen ein prädikat
physisch aus dass im wesentlichen zu tun
hat mit den gesetzen der physik
und sobald leben auftritt nicht
pflanzliches leben müssen wir das
prädikat erweitern
dann kommen wir sozusagen mit diesen
üblichen medikations form nicht hin wir
müssen uns mit phänomenen
auseinandersetzen mit denen wir andere
regularien verbinden und sobald wir dann
auch mit empfinden leben zu tun haben
welcher form auch immer dann brauchen
wir schon das prädikat physisch drei
wandern also ganz traditionell von der
physik über die anorganische chemie in
die organische chemie und in die
biologie und dann sind wir eventuell bei
dem prädikat physisch 4 wo wir dann
normative welten haben in verschiedenen
ausprägungen
hier ist der codex hammurabi abgebildet
und das schöne an dieser aufzählung ist
und dass wir dann vielleicht post
humanisten freuen obwohl ich dieses
projekt eigentlich nicht sehr schätze
spricht nichts dagegen auch ein prädikat
physisch 5 zu haben oder physischen denn
wir haben eine sehr kurze zeit der
entwicklung des homo sapiens sapiens und
vielleicht schaffen sie es ja noch diese
fortzusetzen und in ein ganz anderer
vorstellungswelten noch mit
einzubeziehen
damit komme ich zu meiner diskussion des
begriffs das leben das der lebensformen
die ich beginnen möchte mit überlegungen
von ludwig wittgenstein der
bekanntermaßen den begriff der
lebensform geprägt hat aber auch einen
sehr interessanten vorschlag gemacht hat
wie mit diesem begriff der lebensform
umgegangen werden kann unter bedingungen
moderner philosophischer vorgaben die
klassische stelle der dieses begriffs
der lebensform ist der paragraf 25 aus
den philosophischen untersuchungen wo er
eben davon spricht dass das sprechen der
sprache ein teil ist eine tätigkeit oder
einer lebensform es findet sich dann
noch ein paar andere stellen bei
wittgenstein nicht sehr viele aber
sehr sehr prominent und dann stellt er
diese bekannte liste auch von
tätigkeiten die wir uns hier im
einzelnen vorzustellen haben
ich will auf diese liste aus zeitgründen
jetzt nicht sehr ausführlich eingehen
aber wenn man sich mal anschaut muss ein
2er auffallen diese beispiele der der
alle bringt sind in der tat
kennzeichnend für akteure der human
lebensformen diese dinge die dort
beschrieben werden können nur personen
so wie wir sie üblicherweise als
individuen der human lebensform
begreifen dass andere was hat allerdings
auch auffällt ist dass das sehr
ungeordnet ist nicht und wenn man ein
bisschen böswillig sein wollte den
erinnert das ein bisschen an die an
diese berühmte taxonomie einer gewissen
chinesischen interview wie die von der
woche ist mal gesprochen hat nicht also
wir brauchen ein gewisser hinsicht dann
doch aber eine eine gewisse
regelhaftigkeit um mit diesem begriff
der lebensform umzugehen die uns hier an
dem punkt wittgenstein noch vorhin tätig
werde aber versuchen das im einzelnen
bis hin zu erläutern und wie sie in
regelhaftigkeit auch in dieser dichte
beschreibung wittgensteins einzuführen
in dem philosophischen untersuchungen
erfolgt die einbeziehung der akteurs und
teilnehmer perspektive durch die
exemplifiziert des sprachgebrauchs von
ausdrücken die prominenten position
ahlen einstellung der ersten person
singular tief indikativ präsens aktiv
vorkommen und das ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig dass es in vielen kommentaren
nicht deutlich herausgestellt wurden
wittgenstein diskutiert das immer als
eine einheit von akteurs und teilnehmer
perspektive wir haben es also in den
philosophischen untersuchungen mit einer
innen ausleuchtung der human lebensform
zu tun erhellung im vollzug nicht und
das bild der innen ausleuchtung verweist
auch auf so einen dichten zusammenhang
von erleben verhalten
und handeln auf denen ich im dritten
abschnitt noch ausführlich eingehen
werde
in den semantischen manifestation der
lebensform und ihnen regeln ihres
gebrauche zeigen sich natürliche grenzen
die grammatik als uhr phänomen nicht wie
das bei wittgenstein heißt also es ist
keinesfalls so dass bei allen
konventionellen regeln die wir in den
philosophischen untersuchen dann
vorgeführt bekommen dass das völlig
unabhängig ist von dem was wittgenstein
naturgeschichte nennt sprachspiel und
lebensformen gemeinsam ist der modus
ihres vorliegens im sozialen raum das
ist unbestreitbar aber das sprachspiel
ist etwas unvorhersehbares ist es nicht
begründet nicht vernünftig oder
unvernünftig wie er sagt es steht da wie
unser leben und die lebensform ist in
der hinsicht etwas animalisches jenseits
von der alternative berechtigt und
unberechtigt obwohl sprachspiel und
lebensform in der spezifischen
menschlichen ausprägung erkennbar kultur
produkte sind erscheinen sie aus der
subjektiven perspektive der gelebten
existenz als quasi naturalistische
größen bei wittgenstein und er verweist
denn auch mehrfach auf den zusammenhang
von sprachspiel lebensform und natur
geschichte und ich glaube dass dieser
zusammenhang sehr sehr hilfreich ist mit
dem phänomen der lebensform auch unter
den bedingungen einer analytisch
geklärten philosophie der normativen
institutionen und der person
zurechtzukommen
interessanterweise spricht mit
gletschern auch davon dass die
lebensform etwas ist was mit dem begriff
der mythologie erläutern können die in
den jeweiligen sprachlichen mythologie
niedergelegten überzeugung und
anweisungen bestimmte überzeugungs
einstellungen einzunehmen ist da ein
herr ein system von faktischen
festlegungen die unmittelbar unsere
bedeutungs geschichten formieren diese
impliziten überzeugung sind dann der
ausgangspunkt aller bedeutungs
geschichten nicht etwa nur so detektiv
gewonnen
resultate in dieser mythologie der
sprache ist so etwas wie ein
vermittelndes werkzeug zu sehen dass
sich an der unmittelbarkeit von
handlungs vollzogen orientiert und nicht
etwa an irgendwelchen vermittlungs oder
übersetzungs phänomenen diese funktion
weist mit gestellen den zusammenhang
sehr entschieden zurück die
mythologische funktion der sprache liegt
in ihrer dimensionalen formierung des
sind diese dimensionalen formierung die
den begriff der lebensform wie es jetzt
mal nennen würde einen gewissen sprach
existenziellen sinnvoller in die sprache
ist die gewonnene erfahrung einer
lebensform und in dieser hinsicht
erfüllt sie das was wittgenstein eine
mythologische funktion nennt und ich
beziehe mich da im wesentlichen auf
diese passagen aus der späten schrift
über gewissheit wo er diese art von
mythologie im einzelnen erläutert das
wechselspiel von varian zum in varianz
der gewonnenen erfahrung setzt in der
sprache über die zeit hinweg ist das
formale modell einer kulturgeschichte
der überzeugung in der synchronisierten
mythologie oder meinetwegen auch in
einer mythologischen im unterschied
und da rücken wir jetzt ein bisschen ab
von wittgenstein versuchen noch mehr
regelhaftigkeit in das argument
einzuführen zu individuen anderer
lebensformen entwickeln sich menschliche
individuen zu personen die über sprache
und soziale intelligenz verfügen aber
sie tun das nicht von natur aus aber
auch nicht gegen die natur
sie hatte goalie nicht einfach zeichen
oder gesten sondern drücken epidemische
moralisch und ästhetische verhältnisse
aus und wie vernunft gibt im leben von
personen richtung und zweck und in je
manifestiert sich die perspektive der
menschlichen lebens form in einer
eigentümlichkeit über die wir jetzt noch
abschließend reden müssen
natürliche ordnung zeigen sich
exemplarisch in der abt harten
wirklichkeit eines organismus lebewesen
repräsentieren eine eigene ordnung die
sich zeitweilig gegen die entropie
behauptet ein organismus ins ziel
sozusagen sich vorübergehend der
auflösung in einen thermischen
gleichgewichtszustand aber wir werden
doch sehr schnell verstehen dass diese
bildung zur person nicht etwas ist was
in dieser sichtweise abbildbar ist ich
spiele hier ersichtlich auf schuldiger
das berühmte überlegungen an die
natürlichen ordnung findet der mensch
als gegebenes vor reden wir über die
erste natur innerhalb der natürlichen
welt entwickelt der mensch gleichwohl
die fähigkeit eigene ordnung zu
entwickeln die ihm dann wiederum als
kulturell gegebenes begegnet anders als
natürliche ordnung sind künstliche
ordnung auch in ihrer internen struktur
partiell modifizierbar also der mensch
ist immer an der entwicklung seiner
eigenen naturgeschichte beteiligt darin
besteht der entscheidende unterschied
zwischen natürlicher und künstlicher
ordnung die regeln der human lebensform
sind nicht biologisch verfasst zu den
entscheidenden voraussetzungen und damit
komme ich zum dritten abschnitt unter
den von handlungen im unterschied zu
großen ereignissen die rede sein kann
gehören im unmittelbaren zusammenhang
mit körperbewegungen stehende
bewusstseinszustände des akteurs das
bewusste verhalten von personen kann in
einzelne handlung nach maßgabe von
verhaltens disposition und zielsetzungen
ausdifferenziert und näher beleuchtet
werden
handlungs analysen zielen daher auf
objektivierung von identifizierbaren
bewusstseins episoden in den aktivitäten
und lebens vollzügen der jeweils
handelnden und dieser zusammenhang von
aktiver teilnehmer beobachter
perspektive das ist der entscheidende
punkt den ich jetzt aus dem wittgenstein
scheinargument in das übernehmen was ich
hier eine dichte beschreibung nennen
im unterschied zu lösen ereignissen sind
handlung auf ihre jeweiligen absichten
und gründe hin befragten personen können
in der regel darüber auskunft geben
warum sie den lauf der dinge von auf
bestimmte weise verändert haben
zu jeder bewusst vollzogenen handlungs
geschichte gibt es eine begrenzte anzahl
von aus guten gründen nahegelegten
antworten auf die frage was die
agierende personen beziehungsweise getan
hat die anzahl ist in der regel größer
als der aktionsraum denen diese vor
augen hat wenn sie die frage nach ihren
gegenwärtigen vergangen oder zukünftigen
handel beantwortet denn er hält auch
antworten die zunächst nur dem äußeren
beobachter zur verfügung stehen wie etwa
im fall von eigentümlichkeiten von
verhaltens routinen die der handel als
solche nicht wahrnimmt und die von mit
ihnen vertrauten personen erkannt und
vorausgesagt werden können also es geht
bei der dichte beschreibung keineswegs
um eine privilegierung von subjektiven
perspektiven sondern es geht nach wie
vor um teilnehmer beobachter
perspektiven und der entscheidende punkt
für mich ist dass wir mit dem begriff
der handlung ja etwas zur verfügung
gestellt bekommen was wir beobachten
können was aber aus dem was wir
sozusagen in dünnen beschreibungen
beobachten noch nicht sichtlich er sehen
können was der sinn dieser einzelnen
handlungen ausmacht also ein
entscheidendes theorie stück ist an
dieser unterschied zwischen dichter und
dünner beschreibung wo ich mich im
wesentlichen auf die
unterscheidung von the trial beziehen
und diese unterschied macht uns auch
dann klar warum diese engen form des
naturalismus für eine aufklärung der
lebensform nicht gut geeignet sind
im unterschied zu einer dünnen
beschreibung die ausschließlich zustände
und prozesse im raum der ursachen
verzeichnet können mit der dichten
beschreibung auf vorgehe im raum der
gründe erfasst werden über 3 hat diese
differenz an dem unterschied zwischen
einem zucken von augenlidern und dem
komplexen vorgang eines bedeutungsvollen
zu zwinkern exemplifiziert die stille
kommunikation der gestalt des zwingers
beruht auf einen wechselspiel zwischen
absichten gründen und regeln sie gelingt
unter der voraussetzung dass die am
kommunikativen vorgang beteiligten sich
immer schon regelhaft und in
übereinstimmung mit der human welt
ausgedrückter bedeutung bewegen nur
aufgrund eines geteilten sprachgebrauch
sind die absichten und gründer von einer
anderen person zu erschließen wer diese
regeln nicht kennt der sieht eben in der
augenbewegung nicht ein heimliches
signal sondern schlicht und einfach nur
eine nervöse zuckungen zu den
wesentlichen bestimmungen die in einer
dichten beschreibung kenntlich während
gehören selbstbewusstsein reaktive
haltungen wie etwa arm oder empörung
sowie situations bewusstsein dass ein
unmittelbares bewusstsein von der
präsenz anderer person einschließt usw
die sich in der dichten beschreibung
manifestierende ausdrucks welt erlaubt
innerhalb eines begrenzten spielraums
annahmen vermutungen und erklärung
hinblick auf eigene handlungen und
handlungen anderer personen und diese
mutmaßung können wiederum von den
handeln wieder beobachten personen zum
gegenstand weiterer überlegungen gemacht
werden die gegebenenfalls auch zum
bezweifeln und verwerfen der jeweiligen
annahmen
können unabhängig von skeptischen
erwägungen wird das verhalten von
personen in der regel als ein handeln
begriffen dass von bestimmungen wie
selbstbewusstsein sprache reaktiven
haltungen intentionen gründen wissen und
bewertungen zweiter stufe stufe bestimmt
wird und das ist das was ich mir unter
dem prädikat vier physisch 4 dann im
einzelnen vorstellen
im handel bezieht sich die personen mit
gründen auf sich selbst und die
situation in der sie sich gerade
befindet auch wenn die gründe der
jeweils handelnden personen in einem
starken sinne an ihre besondere
perspektive und situation gebunden sind
können sie grundsätzlich auch von
anderen personen verstanden werden
unabhängig davon ob diese sie sich zu
eigen machen und damit sind wir jetzt im
stand so einen ersten überblick zu
nehmen was wir jetzt den paragraf 25 von
wittgensteins philosophischen
untersuchungen an stärkerer
regelhaftigkeit an die seite stellen
können
und der sinn jetzt dieser listen ist
dass wir sie begreifen als eine offene
liste der aber nur eigenschaften und
fähigkeiten benannt werden die für
personen eigentümlich sind die also
genuin personale eigenschaften sind und
das heißt jetzt tauchen überall
ausdrücke auf die wir mit den prädikaten
physisch 1 bis 3 eben nicht erfassen
können nicht da gehören umgang mit
möglichen welten zusammen einfach diese
banale frage dass wir uns permanent in
unseren handlungs vollzügen fragen
können was wäre wenn
was wäre wenn ich heute morgen nicht
verschlafen hätte oder was wäre wenn ich
diesen zu machen würde und einen anderen
unterlasse alle diese dinge bestimmen
die art und weise wie wir in die welt
schauen und die bestimmt auch die weise
wie wir menschen unter umständen für
zurechenbarkeit oder
verantwortlichkeiten
wir werden diese liste nicht jetzt im
einzelnen durchgehen können aber wir
können sie einteilen in gruppen um nicht
jetzt in diese verlegenheit dieser
gewissen chinesischen taxonomie zu
kommen und die art und weise wie man
diese listen im eigentlichen sinne dann
organisiert die ist nicht festzulegen
und wir sollten das als etwas begreifen
was eine offene liste ist und das
interessante dabei ist wenn man schaut
dass theorien der humanen lebensformen
sich oft auf solche prozesse
konzentrieren die mit verstehen
überhaupt mit systemischen einstellung
zu tun haben stellt man fest dass das
menschliche leben offensichtlich
wesentlich breiter angelegt etwas ganz
handfeste konsequenzen hat wenn man im
fall von neurodegenerativen erkrankungen
sieht dass diese bereiche verblassen
eben andere bereiche noch sehr wohl
intakt sind was im einzelnen dann auch
durchaus ansätze für therapeutische
optionen bietet das ist also dieses
angebot was mit einer dichten
beschreibung im zuge eines erweiterten
naturalismus und aufbereitet werden kann
und damit da gar kein falscher eindruck
entsteht das ist jetzt keine hohe zeit
der bis an die x rationale sondern zu
den spezifischen eigenschaften dieser
humanes gehört natürlich auch
inhumanität grausamkeit dummheit und
wenn ich eine handlung als grausam
bezeichne beschreibend habe ich im
grunde genommen schon eine person
identifiziert nicht das ist auch der
witz dieser aufzählungen das sich hinter
diesen beschreibung jeweils schon
identifikations situation verbergen die
auf akteure der human lebensform
verweisen
ich halte diese dichte beschreibung für
eine naturalistische methode zur
erfassung der eigenheiten der human
lebensform weil
die sich immer auf beobachtbare
essverhalten bezieht sie gehen nicht von
einer anthropologischen wesens
bestimmung aus sondern erfasst und
interpretiert das was akteure der
humanen lebensform personen erleben und
tun
die dichte beschreibung unterscheidet
sich von einer dünnen beschreibung eben
durch diese einbeziehung der akteure und
teilnehmer perspektive das ist ein ganz
wichtiges theorie stück in diesem
zusammenhang die eigenschaften und
fähigkeiten die in der dichten
beschreibung der fast werden drücken
sich kontext relativ aus und das heißt
im übrigen nicht nur dass wir in die
natur schauen sondern das heißt auch
stadt und land das sollte nicht
vergessen werden wenn wir über meine
lebensform reden über zweite natur reden
wir über die kultur die wir in den
metropolen vorfinden dior der ort der
humanen lebensform ist also nicht die
natur was immer das im einzelnen ist
sondern die hochgradig verästelte zweite
natur die natürlich immer im
zusammenhang mit der erste natur steht
und das heißt aber eben in den meisten
fällen die stadt in diesem sinne kann
auch walter benjamins passagenwerk als
dichte beschreibung im sinne eines
anthropologischen materialismus
beziehungsweise naturalismus bezeichnet
werden und da haben wir in jedem fall
wunderbare ein knüpfung
anknüpfungspunkte für diese
eigenschaften und fähigkeiten die dann
auch in anderen kontexten sich
offensichtlich zumindest in den
ästhetischen ausgestaltungen anders
präsentieren
aber das ist ein weiterer vortrag den
ich heute nicht halten möchte und ich
bedanke mich herzlich für ihre
aufmerksamkeit